تنطلقوا بعد ساعات قليله بطوله كاس العالم
لكره القدم قطر 2022 وصلت تاكيدا من
السلطات القطريه للجاهزيه الكامله لانجاح
المناسبه الرياضيه التي تعد الاكبر عالميا
وفي ظل الاشاده بما تم تنفيذه من
استعدادات اللوجستيه متقدمه للخروج بنسخه
غير مسبوقه من مونديال تعد قطر او اول
دوله عربيه ومسلمه تنظمه ما جعل المنطقه
وشعوبها محطه الانظار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات من رسائل التي يحملها
نجاح دوله عربيه في الاستعداد الاستضافه
حدث ضخما بحجم كاس العالم لكره القدم
وماذا يعني ذلك على المسارين الثقافي
والرياضي اي دلالات للشهاده التي اطلقها
رئيس الفيفا لصالح قطر وحديثه عن ازدواجيه
المعايير لدى الغرب واي اثر سيتركه هذا
تنظيم على نظره الغربيه والتموضع الغربي
للعبه كره القدم باعتبارها الصناعه رائجه
ومملوكه لدول العالم الاول
وما العائد المادي والحضاري الذي سينتج عن
تنظيم هذا الحدث لقطر ودول المنطقه وكيف
للدول العربيه والاسلاميه وعامه دول الشرق
الاوسط انت تستثمر في خصوصا ما تعلق
بالصوره الذهنيه النمطيه لها عند الغرب
[موسيقى]
بمعايره عديده ووازنه يبشروا مونديال قطر
2022 بنسخه مميزه واستثنائيه من كاس
العالم لكره القدم فبعد ساعات قليله
تنطلقوا التظاهره الرياضيه الاهم والاضخم
في المعموره لتخطف الانظار وتملا الاسماء
ليس فقط بمنافساتها الدوليه الممتعه وانما
كذلك بمستوى من التجهيزات ونوعيه من
الملاعب وبنيه تحتيه تعد الافضل عالميا
وفي مراوحه مميزه بين الشكل والمضمون
تراهن دوله قطر على معادله تحتفي ضمنها
بالتنوع الانساني بنفس المستوى الذي تجسد
فيه الضيافه العربيه والاصاله الاسلاميه
لتثبت للعالم ان حدوده لا تنتهي عند الغرب
وان النجاح في انجاز المواسم الرياضيه
الكبرى ليس حكرا على فئه من البشر دون
اخرى وفي ذلك استثمار يتجاوز
قطر الى منطقه عربيه اسلاميه تكافح لتغيير
صوره نمطيه التي يراد لها ان تبقى اسيره
فيها رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
جياني انفانتينو اكد الجاهزيه دوله قطر
التامه لاستضافه افضل كاس للعالم وكذلك
استعداد القائمين على البطوله لتوفير
اجواء امنه للجماهير
الدوحه جاهزه قطر جاهزه ستكون افضل بطوله
فهذا ما يريده المشجعون هناك اكثر من
100,000 شخص مستعدون للحدث الكبير
واستقبال اكثر من نصف مليون زائر لمتابعه
البطوله جميع القائمين على البطوله
مستعدون لخدمه ضيوف المونديال وتوفير
اجواء امنه لهم في كافه المناحي من
الاقامه والمعيشه والطعام
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الكويت
الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت ومن الدوحه على
صادق المحلل والناقد الرياضي مرحبا بكم
ابدا معك دكتور عبد الله الشارجي قطر اذا
جاهزه لاستضافه الحدث الابرز
عالميا رياضيا يعني لاول مره كره القدم في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي دوله عربيه
اسلاميه ما الذي يحمله تنظيم مثل هذا
الحدث الاهم من تاثيرات على الصوره
الذهنيه لشعوبها لدى العالم
شكرا لكم طبعا حلقه مهمه في اعتقادي وكوني
رديت من الدوحه كنت في الدوحه
بالويكاند وشفنا يعني ورشه ما شاء الله
يعني شيء مميز في كل شيء وواضح ان
الاستعدادات على قدر الامن وساق وغدا
الانطلاق وطبعا يعني هذه اول مره نبارك
اول شيء لقطر ونتمنى لها النجاح
والتميز بالفعل كما يقول لانفنتينا الرئيس
الاتحاد الدوري لكره القدم يتوقع ان تكون
هذه البطوله كاس العالم في قطر ستكون
الاكثر تميزا ونجاحا والاستعدادات تثبت
ذلك على جميع النواحي يعني لا شك ان قطر
حققت انجازا ااه لم تحقق اي دوله عربيه
واسلاميه وامكانيه ثانيه دوله في الشرق
قاره اسيا همم تستضيف كاس العالم اللي هي
تظاهره عالميه ملياريه وهذا طبعا يعطي قطر
الكثير من
انتباه الكثير من المتابعه لمعرفه ما هي
قطر اين قطر ما هي التقاليد ما هي العادات
واعتقاد ايضا المهم جدا والحمله الشرسه
والمنهجه التي تتبعها بعض الدول في الغرب
وسائل الاعلام اللي بالفعل يعني قاعد شن
حمله شرسه يعني قبل يومين قرات في نيويورك
تايمز خبر الفريق المنسي عن العماله التي
بنت تحتيه
والملاعب السادات الموجوده وكذلك في السي
ان ان وكذلك في الاعلام البريطاني حمله
ممنهجه حول حقوق الانسان وحول حقوق
المثليين وغيرهم لنقل ثقافتهم الى الى الى
بلادنا طبعا هذا مرفوض وانا سعيد ان ارى
قطر اتخذت امس قرار مع الفيفا بمنع بيع
البيره والكحول في الملاعب وهذه عده دول
في اوروبا تقوم بها ولم نسمع لهم اي
انتقاد
لتلك الدول التي تقوم بمنع بيع الخمر في
البيره في الملاعب اثناء المباريات هذه
الحمله واضح جدا هدفها هو ان لا همم تمحى
الفكره والنمط السلبي المنهج الستاريو
تايبنج كما نسميه في الاعلام من عقليه
الغائب وعقليه المواطنين الغربيين الذين
معظمهم واغلبتهم الساحقه يرون بالعرب
والمسلمين وارهابيين والبعض يعني بساداجته
وكنا في امريكا يعني نسال وانا مع مع بعض
الامريكيين يرون يسالون هل انتم لا زلتم
تعيشون في الخيام هل تركبون الجمال هل
عندكم طرق هل عندكم سيارات يعني هذه
الصغرى بالفعل يريدونها ان لا ان تبقى
مرتبطه يعني ما نقول عربي ومسلم وهولي
والكره ذلك همم والاعلام الاسرائيلي
والصهيوني يريد ان يبقي هذه الصوره همم في
ذاكره وفي عقليه الغربيين فعندما ياتوا
شفنا الانبهار يعني كنت انا في امس بالفعل
هناك انبهار عند السياح في ال- في الاسواق
التجاريه في الفندق اللي كنت في كان جميع
الحكام موجودين في وكانوا يستمتعون
ويسبحون في السباحه في الخارج ويعني في
بالفعل هذا انجاز قافل بالاضافه لاستضافتك
كاس العالم هو تصحيح الصوره النبطيه
السلبيه عن قطر الاسلام وراينا ايضا كيف
قطر تهتم بنشر تعليم الاسلام السمحاء
واحاديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم موجوده
في في الشوارع وكذلك احضار همم ذاكر
الهندي همم
للحديث عن الاسلام ايضا فهي فرصه جيده
همم يعني هي عمليه تصدير همم لهذه الصوره
وهذه الجاهزيه في هذه الصوره الزاهيه
والمبهره من خلال جاهزيتها لاستضافه هذا
الحدث دكتور علاء الرسائل التي تبعث بها
دوله قطر على المسارين الثقافي ايضا
والرياضي باتجاه دول العالم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ارحب بحضرتك
وباللدكتور عبد الله وبالساده المشاهدين
واود ان اركز على نقطه بالغه الاهميه ان
نجاح قطر هو نجاح للمنطقه كامله ليس نجاح
للدوله ولا لجيرانها فقط ولكن نجاح لمنطقه
كامله تجاهلها العالم لفتره طويله
حرص قطر على عدم التنازل عن مبادئها مقابل
تنظيم هذا الحدث الضخم شيء مختلف لدى
الغرب عن العالم في تلك المنطقه هما
اعتدوا ان يتنازل الكثيرون في تلك المنطقه
الامور كثيره مقابل رضا الغرب عنهم فما
بالك وانت تنظم اكبر تظاهره رياضيه كرويه
في العالم تظاهره لم تتمكن دوله الصين حتى
هذه اللحظه من تنظمها تظاهره لم تتمكن
قاره استراليا التي نظمت الاوليمبياد
مرتين ان تنظمها هذا امر كبير قطر تقول
للعالم انها وان المنطقه تستطيع نستطيع
فعلا ان ننظم المهام الكبرى نستطيع ان
نكون مواكبين للعمل الجماعي هذا العمل
الجماعي بشكل خيالي تابعته بشخص هذا العمل
من داخل الدوحه لمده ثمان سنوات متصله في
تلك السنوات
طق طقاطر على دوله قطر اكثر من 100 شخصيه
من 100 دوله مختلفه للعمل في كاس العالم
في زوايا واتجاهات مختلفه يسعدني جدا ان
اشيد بان قطر غيرت صوره المواطن في تلك
المنطقه من الشخص الحريص على الاستهلاك
الحريص على الانفاق الحريص على المتعه غير
الحريص على التعلم غير الحريص على العمل
الجماعي الى دوله تنظم اكبر تظاهره بكفاءه
غير مسبوقه من فضل الله تابعت كاس العالم
بتركيز بتركيز كبير من عام 1962
و66 في انجلترا والنهايه بروسيا 2018 وكنت
موجوده في مو في تلك البطوله ما يحدث في
قطر مغاير كل الدول تسعى في تلك البطولات
لامتصاص او ادخال ايديها في جيوب القادمين
للحصول على الاموال
قد لادخال البهجه على القلوب وعلى العقول
دون النظر لما سيعود عليها من اموال بدليل
ان كل المواصلات كل المواصلات مجانيه ان
العلاج لضيوف كاس العالم مجاني امور لا
يمكن ان تجديها في اي دوله اخرى في العالم
قطر غيرت وجه المنطقه وتلك هي النقطه او
الزاويه الرئيسيه التي ينتعض الغرب من
حدوثها وكانوا لا يتمنون ان يروها وهذا سر
عدائهم الشديد
دكتور عبد الله الشايجي هي بصمه مميزه
تتركها قطر همم والنسيج يدخل ضمن همم يعني
همم
اشكال العده التي جرى تنظيمها لمونديالات
عديده جدا ببصمه عربيه
اسلاميه خاصه لدوله قطر اي اثر سيتركه هذا
التنظيم بهذه الجهوزيه العاليه على النظره
الغربيه والصوره النمطيه
لدى الغرب للعبه كره القدم باعتبارها هي
عباره عن صناعه
رائجه ومملوكه فقط
لدول العالم الاول
ناحيه مهمه كسرت الاحتكار يعني 17 دوله في
العالم فقط نظمت كاس العالم منذ الثلاثين
منذ عام 30 في القرن الماضي بعد الدول
نظماتها حتى مرتين بما فيها فرنسا
والبرازيل والمكسيك والمانيا
فقدنا الصوت مع الدكتور عبد الله الشاي
سنعود اليه حاله ما نتمكن من التواصل معه
بهذا السؤال احيله لك الدكتور علاء صادق
يعني
عاده معنا عاده معنا الدكتور عبد الله
تفضل تفضل اسمع كلامه
ايجابيه كما ذكرت عن العرب
عندما تنظم انت كاس العالم فانت بهذه
الطريقه يمكنك ان تنظم اي بطوله اخرى او
اي تظاهره عالميه بالنسبه الى قطر يعني
يمكنها ان تنجح
بان تستضيف احداث ومهرجانات وبطولات
عالميه كبرى وليس فقط عندما تصل الى تنظيم
كاس العالم وهي كما ذكرت قطر الدوله
الثامنه عشر التي ستنظم هذه البطوله فانت
بلغت يعني قمه القدره على ان تنظم اهم
الاحداث الرياضيه وهذا يعطي ليس قطر فقط
مثل ما ذكر الاستاذ على وكذلك سمو امير
قطر من هذه البطوله هي للعرب جميع وليس
للقطريين وكلنا نسخر الان بان قطر كعرب
كخليجيين وكمسلمين همم تنجح بان تنظم هذه
البطوله لترسق صوره ايجابيه عن العرب لان
هناك يعني الحمله جزء منها انهم لا يستوي
لا يستوعبون او لا يريدون ان يتقبلوا ان
دوله همم صغيره بشرق الاوسط عربيه
واسلاميه تنظم اهم حدث رياضي في العالم
وهذا بحتى انجاز كبير لدوله قطر لتصريح
هذه المفاهيم الخاطئه الدكتور علاء ما
دلاله شهاده رئيس الفيفا يعني انفنتينو
اليوم همم لصالح دوله قطر وحديثه عن
ازدواجيه معايير الغرب
اولا ارفع القبعه لهذا الرجل السويسري
اوروبيه مئه بالمئه تحدث بشجاعه وبصراحه
افتقدناها كثيرا من عليت القوم في اوروبا
حتى من رؤساء الدول ومن المسؤولين الكبار
عندما قال ان الرياء والنفاق لدى
الاوروبيين سبب الرئيسي لما يفعلونه عندما
قال ان الاستعلام على العرب وان الامر له
علاقه بالعرق والدين كان شجاعا للغايه
ولكن لابد ان ننظر الى الموضوع بنظره اعمى
لان الحرب الشرسه الان قبل ايام قليله من
انطلاق المونديال كان يجب ان تكون منذ 12
عاما في عام 2010 عندما فازت قطر بحق
التنظيم على الحساب الولايات المتحده كان
المت طبعا ان تكون الحمله شرسه في مدار 12
عاما تاخرت كثيرا لماذا اولا لم يكن لدى
الغرب ذره شك ان قطر لن تاني هم شهدوا
الامر كابوسا بينما شاهدناه حلما والكابوس
والحلم معا امور غير حقيقيه امور غير
واقعيه هم اعتقدوا ان قطر ستفشل يوما بعده
وما اكثر الدول التي طلبت التنظيم عجزت عن
التنظيم مثل كولومبيا في 86 وغيره ولكن
عندما اصبح الامر حقيقه واقعه
واكتشف الغرب ان الامر ليس كابوسا وانه
اصبح واقعا مريرا عليهم بدات الازدواجيه
في اعلى درجاتها هم ينظرون الينا دائما
نظره استعلاء نحن اقل منه في كل شيء
وللاسف اوده كمان ان اكون امينا نحن
ساعدناهم كثيرا ساعدهم مثلا عندما تجده
مدرب منتخب لكره القدم عندما يكون مصريا
زي حسام البدري يتقاضى 10 قروش وياتي
الاجنبي بعده كيروس ليتقدم 100 قرش ثم
ياتي المصري ايهاب جلال يتقاضى 10 قروش ثم
ياتي البرتغالي فيتوريا ليتقدم 100 قرش
نحن ساعدناهم ليس فقط في مجال الرياضه
ولكن في مجال العلوم والهندسه والحمد لله
ان انا وصلنا الى المرحله التي توقف هذا
الامر ونوقف هذا الفارق الذي س- صنعنا جزء
منه لدى الاوروبيين الذين يعتقدون انه
مجرد وجودهم في العالم العربي هو مصلحه
للعالم العربي هو من من الاوروبيين علينا
عندما ياتون للعمل عندنا يقول الحمد لله
اصبح لدينا منها الكفاءات في كل مجال نحن
قطر تنظم كاس العالم بلجنه من الارث
تقريبا تقريبا 80% من قادتها القطريون 80%
من قادتها شباب صغير جدا شباب في
الثلاثينيات ومطلع الاربعينيات نحن نستطيع
الارث الحقيقي لتلك البطوله ليس البنيه
التحتيه العظيمه التي تتواجد في قطر
وستفيدها لعشرات السنين الارث الحقيقي هو
اننا كسرنا حاجز الاستعلام سبحان الله
وفي حديث الارث هذا الدكتور عبد الله
الشايجي
يصنف هذا النجاح لدوله قطر في الجوزيه
لاستضافات هذا الحدث على انه نجاح المنطقه
الان كيف يمكن
للمنطقه همم العربيه لدول الشرق الاوسط
انت تستمر هذا الحدث الابرز لصالحها برايك
يعني هي النظره الايجابيه فيعتقد نجاح قطر
في استضافه كاس العالم كدوله عربيه
وخليجيه ومسلمه هو نجاح لنا جميعا هو
تثبيت بان نقادرون بان كل الكلام وكل
الحمله المنهجه السلبيه
للاضرار بالصور او لترسيخ الصوره السلبيه
النمطيه عن المنطقه بانها من منطقه لا
يمكنها ان
تحقق انجازات لا يمكنها ان تستضيف عليه
ضخمه عالميه بهذا المستوى المتميز ونجاح
ان شاء الله ال ال الاستضافه والبطوله
وسيكون بالفعل رصيد مهم يضاف الى الرصيد
العربي والخليجي وانا بالفعل يعني وانا
اريد ان اكد على نقطه مهمه انا دول الخليج
الان هي القائد الفعلي النظام العرب يعني
برغم الازمه الخليجيه التي عدت بعد ثلاث
سنوات ونصف اننا الان يمكننا ان نكون بان
نحن السنتر نحن الفوكس نحن تركيز همم
استضافه همم يعني العالم همم ايضا يعني
همم في دبي كان اكسبو 20 20 العام القادم
بعد مصر كوب 20 28 قمه المناخ فالمركز
والثقل العربي اصبح في منطقتنا واستضافه
قطر لكاس العالم بهذا الاسلوب وبهذا
التميز وشفنا الملاعب وشفنا الاستعدادات
وشفنا الحماس بنشوفوا الانقطعوضونا انت
وحماس الجماهير العربيه اربع منتخبات
عربيه تتنافس هذا كله سيعطي الغرب وخاصه
ال- ال- الاعلام الغربي الذي سيطر ان ينقل
هذه المباريات والاجواء وان النجاح
والتنظيم سيكرر الصوره نمطيه مميزه جدا
لنا جميعا في الخليج والعالم العربي
والاسلام هايبر
احلى في حديث العوائد همم برايك يعني بغض
النظر عن العائد المادي والذي تحدث بانه
ليس لديه ذاك الاعتبار الكبير ربما اا
طالما ذكرت بان يعني قطر تنظر الى اهميه
هذه الاستضافه بهذه همم الجهوزيه العاليه
وتقديم كل هذه الخدمات للجماهير نتحدث عن
العائد الحضاري العائد الانساني ما هو
اثره وما هو المنتظر العائد الحضاري خيالي
فوق الخيال اكثر جدا همم لا يمكننا الوصول
اليه حتى بعقولنا عندما تفكر قبل 10 سنوات
ان قطر ستنظم كاس العالم لكره القدم لا
يصدقك احد مطلقه عندما تقدمت ضد امريكا
موضوع خارج اطار العقل فكيف وكاس العالم
ستنطلق غدا مباراه قطر
العائد ليس في البنيه التحتيه فقط وليس في
العوائد الماليه على الاط وليس في استضافه
قطر لاحقا ان شاء الله لبطولات كبرى وهي
تمتلك من الملاعب ما يؤهلها لتنظيم عشرات
من البطولات الكبرى تبدا بكاس اسيا في
يناير المقبل ولكن اريد ان اركز على عائد
حضاري من زاويه اخرى جدا يتحدثون عن
العولمه
ويعتقدون انهم ملوك العولمه والغربي يقول
انه سيد العولمه نحن نتحدث عن دوله
تعدادها من المواطنين يقل عن النصف مليون
مساحتها تقل عن 12,000 كيلو متر مربع
وتنظم حدثا كان لدى روسيا في الدوره
الماضيه ومساحتها 17 مليون كم مربع
واتعدادها فوق 300 مليون نسمه ولكن هنا
العولمه الحقيقيه كيف تمكنت قطر
بنظام في قمه الدقه من تكثيف كل دول
العالم
في كل الكفاءات في العالم ليتواجدوا في
تلك البقعه ليعمل كل منهم في المكان
المخصص له بنظام يعجز الكمبيوتر عن تنفيذه
هذا هو النجاح هذه الحضاره قطر سنتر او
مركز العولمه الحقيقيه في العالم في هذا
القرن شكرا لك من الدوحه الدكتور علاء
صادق المحلل والناقد الرياضي ومن الكويت
الدكتور عبدالله الشارجي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت شكرا جزيلا لكما
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء بحول الله
[موسيقى]